they call that a Hail Mary that's what
they do when uh they put you on EO
machine when it's a Hail Mary and five
people were on ECMO that night and the
other four died and and I somehow made
it well um what God is a is a fan yeah I
mean I know you're feeling about that um
but I I well I know that I'm a fan maybe
I'm okay I I know that uh once you've
referred to it as a force and you know
it I believe I believe that I believe
that a higher power there is higher
power I believe I've had a very close
relationship with him some people are
going to recoil just a little bit from
Matthew Perry using this vague language
of a higher power but first of all he's
talking to Bill Maher who's one of the
most famous atheists in the country so I
think he's just trying to get through to
him a little bit it's not a debate that
they're having and then even when he
says look you've talked about like a for
spill well yeah that's kind of what I
believe in and I think I have a close
relationship with him